[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de ce jeudi 21 octobre
le point sur les dégâts engendrés par la
tempête aurore le phénomène
météorologique est passé cette nuit par
le département 70 interventions de
pompiers ont été nécessaires et des
foyers ont été privés de courant une
réunion qui a convié représentants des
collectivités de la sécurité ce jeudi à
la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux à l'invitation de l'opérateur
ses new line numérique les participantes
abordé le thème de la vidéo protection
et d'une potentielle mutualisation des
moyens à ce sujet nous recevons le
député des yvelines philippe benassaya
et puis un budget qui est passée de 3,5
milliards à plus de 5 milliards d'euros
le coût des vols ce prolongement du rer
e jusqu'à mantes la jolie des rails et
de quoi inquiéter ou suscité la colère
du département des yvelines et de la
région ile-de-france le projet est il
menacé pour autant nous en parlons dans
un instant retour également sur la venue
cette semaine d'eric zemmour à
versailles le polémiste annoncé comme
probable candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle at il un
potentiel électoral dans le département
éléments de réponse tout à l'heure dans
ce journal
[Musique]
mais d'abord le début de cette édition
avec les conséquences de la tempête
aurore qui est passé par le département
cette nuit alerte orange levée au vent
violent dès 8 heures ce matin par météo
france dans la région les rafales ont
atteint par endroits plus de 100
kilomètres/heure des effets plutôt
limitée dans les yvelines pas de blessés
à déplorer mais tout de même 70
interventions des pompiers entre 21h et
8 heures du matin pour des chutes
d'arbres et de branches et les agents
dans les communes également été
largement mobilisés ce matin comme ici à
plaisir ou les ont été à pied d'oeuvre
dans le parc du château est également
dans le quartier des gâtines autre
exemple à poissy où comme dans d'autres
communes yvelinoise des arbres sont
tombés par endroits interventions des
agents pour sécuriser les lieux à noter
que le plan orsec orange a été
déclenchée dès 5 heures du matin dans le
département il permet une mobilisation
rapide et coordonnée des moyens sous
l'autorité du préfet et ce jeudi matin
une quinzaine interne d'intervention 2
sécurisation étaient également menées
dans certaines pour rétablir le courant
dans la moitié nord du pays jusqu'à 250
mille foyers ont été privés
d'électricité ene 10 a dépêché 40
techniciens dans les départements de des
yvelines et du val d'oise est des
opérations pour réalimenter les clients
dans les plus brefs délais c'était le
cas ce matin au mesnil saint denis sur
ces images où une trentaine de foyers
étaient concernées les propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude suite à
la tempête horreur de cette nuit il ya
une chute d'arbres sur une de nos lignes
aériennes basse tension et du coup on
vient pour réparer aujourd'hui la ligne
en question pour pouvoir réalimenter les
clients qui sont coupés depuis cette
nuit on est sur une liaison entre deux
postes et on peut faire une réparation
provisoire pour alimenter au plus vite
les clients sans devoir remonter tout le
réseau existant un incident électrique
près de chez vous et les 10 rappelle
quelques bons gestes ne jamais toucher
deux fils à terre ou d'objets en contact
avec une ligne électrique signaler toute
anomalie est respectée également les
zones banaliser la dernière conséquence
en train de cette tempête aurores dans
le département des yvelines des
transports perturbés à cause de chutes
d'arbres et de soucis électriques il a
été très difficile ce matin par exemple
de circuler sur le rer a ou c est par
endroits avec des interruptions de
trafic ou encore de gros ralentissements
sur les lignes du transilien n et u est
le retour à la normale est intervenue
peu à peu dans la journée rester informé
sur les sites de la ratp et de
transilien est dans l'actualité du jour
également le déplacement du premier
ministre jean castex dans les yvelines
le premier ministre était cet après midi
à saint germain en laye en compagnie de
la secrétaire d'état à l'économie
sociale solidaire et responsable olivia
grégoire au programme de la visite
lequel est possible un tiers lieux qui
propose des formations vers les métiers
en tension le numérique et la création
d'entreprises ont encore des chantiers
d'insertion professionnelle une
structure qui s'adresse aux personnes
éloignées de l'emploi jean castex a
ensuite parcouru les rues de la ville en
compagnie du maire de saint germain en
laye arnaud péricard
[Musique]
j'accueille à présent en plateau mon
invité de ce journal c'est philippe
benassaya bonsoir bonsoir député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines avec
vous on va parler de la vidéoprotection
et des évolutions législatives qui ont
été engagés par la loi pour une sécurité
globale qui a été promulguée a déjà le
25 mai dernier mais d'abord direction
montigny le bretonneux seine et yvelines
numériques a organisé ce jeudi à la
ferme du mal est une matinée de
conférences sur la vidéoprotection
mutualisé est l'occasion de présenter le
futur projet de l'entité en proposant
des collaborations sur la
vidéoprotection entre communes au sein
d'une même intercommunalité le reportage
de nicolas d'andré
une vidéoprotection piloté par seine et
yvelines numériques pour les communes et
intercommunalités le projet en cours
d'élaboration par le syndicat mixte un
sujet sur lequel est engagé le
conseiller départemental yvelinois
patrick stefanini ce syndicat va pouvoir
intervenir auprès des communes à leur
demande à la fois pour les aider
financièrement à acquérir à installer et
à maintenir les matériels mais également
seine et yvelines numériques pourra
faire du visionnage pour le compte des
communes et du visionnage h 24
comme ce syndicat le fait déjà pour le
compte du département sur les bâtiments
départementaux aujourd'hui le projet est
en cours de conception les membres de
senna yvelines numériques consulte les
maires et élus intercommunaux c'était le
cas lors de cette conférence organisée
le jeudi 21 octobre à la ferme du manet
objectif final mettre en place des
centres de supervision sur le territoire
maire de cheuvreux à néry le pallec
présentes lors de cette matinée est
intéressé par la démarche l'évolution
législative va vraiment permettre ça en
s'appuyant sur des dispositifs qui sont
mutualisés à beaucoup plus grande
échelle donc les moyens du département
avec avec son bras armé le syndicat
seine yvelines numériques et d'être
beaucoup plus dans une action préventive
que dans une action répressive les
centres de supervision serait
directement en relation avec les polices
municipales nationale et la gendarmerie
une phase opérationnelle pourrait être
lancée l'année prochaine sur des
communes ou intercommunalités des
yvelines
philippe et asseyant vient de le voir
dans ce sujet la loi permet aujourd'hui
un syndicat mixte de prendre en charge
la vidéoprotection communales et
intercommunales
vous avez d'ailleurs voté pour la loi
pour une sécurité globale qui amène
quelques changements législatifs on va
les voir s'afficher tout d'abord les
syndicats peuvent mettre à disposition
des communes ou des intercommunalités ou
des départements également concernés du
personnel pour visionner les images
nouvelles aussi modifications ces agents
de communes et des intercommunalités
aussi des syndicats mixtes peuvent être
chargés du visionnage des images qui ont
été prises sur la voie publique au moyen
d'un dispositif de vidéoprotection dès
lors que ce visionnage ne nécessite pas
de leur part des actes de police
judiciaire quels sont les objectifs qui
sont apportées justement par ces
modifications législatives que
permettait finalement ces modifications
alors il faut savoir d'abord que cette
question est ancienne 1 il ya eu des
modifications législatives où l'avait
dit et des agglomérations avaient
souvent cette cette compétence la 2d ce
qu'on appelle laissés sur les centres de
supervision urbain c'est une histoire
ancienne qui vient d'être remaut dernis
et si j'ai quelques secondes je vous
explique en général les images sont vus
dans des centres de supervision urbain
cessant de supervision urbain soit sont
à la charge de la commune 60 a la chance
d agglomération moi en tant que
vice-président l'époque de versailles
grand parc puisque bois d'arcy dans
versailles grand parc quand j'étais
maire de bois d'arcy j'avais la
compétence vidéoprotection et donc mon
objectif
à l'époque il ya maintenant des années
c'était non seulement l'installation des
caméras sur l'agglomération mais
également de créer des centres de
supervision urbain à l'intérêt même de
verser un grand parc mais li zhi
versailles fontaine fleurie on avait
trois et six ans de supervision pouvait
nous permettre de voir les images dans
toutes les communes donc ça ça existait
déjà depuis longtemps la grande
nouveauté c'est que maintenant ça
yvelines numériques qui regardez les
images des bâtiments départementaux peut
maintenant regarder toutes les autres
images ce qui fait qu'on renforce
l'arsenal et puis il ya une troisième
point que je voulais voir avec vous r
très rapidement c'est que j'ai fait
adopter un amendement ce qui est rare
puisque je suis pas dans la majorité
mais j'ai fait adopter un amendement qui
est très important c'est à dire quand il
ya des villes par exemple ou des petites
villes dont la communauté de communes
n'a pas la compétence sécurité elles
sont coincés parce qu'elles ne peuvent
pas visionné les images personne peut
visionner leur image et donc elles
peuvent s'adosser sur des communautés
d'agglomération voisine et l'amendement
a été adopté je prends l'exemple dans ma
circonscription 10 minutes saint denis
c'est une petite commune et la
communauté de communes n'a pas la
compétence sécurité donc j'ai demandé à
ce que les images du minime soit
regardée par saint quentin en yvelines
et pour cela il fallait faire un
amendement parce qu'on change de
frontières on change de l'agglomération
dont vous voyez que le sujet est en
train de grossir il y avait une époque
souvenez vous il ya une dizaine d'années
la vidéo protection les centres de
supervision grosso modo c'était plutôt
les villes de droite qu'ils aient les
villes de gauche était plutôt réticente
maintenant je pense qu'il ya plus de
débat jeudi concerne plus de deux
personnes en quoi justement cette
mutualisation territoriale des moyens
permettait d'avoir une vidéo protection
plus efficace pour lutter par exemple
contre l'inde est l'un comme la
délinquance oui il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'autres choses lutter contre
l'un des vacances vous voyez comment
sont faites les images à bord les images
sont floutés pour tout ce qui est privé
tout ce qui est bâtiments privés et
lutter contre la délinquance
humaine la délinquance routière
également c'est très important il y as
on est en train de passer à la vidéo
verbalisation cidre ou et de tout
l'arsenal de sécurité est en train
d'être modifiées en france pourquoi
parce que la compétence sécurité est en
train de descendre de plus en plus sur
les communautés de communes et de
collectivités donc on est devant une
vraie révolution de la sécurité et des
images des cyber et de la cybersécurité
en france aujourd'hui nous faisait pas
forcément que pour lutter contre la
délinquance ça peut servir aussi à ça
peut être si délaissé supérieur de 100
de supervision des banques deviennent
des csu 2.0 c'est à dire qu'on peut
actionner à distance de votre série su
avec les caméras que vous avez vous
pouvez actionner par exemple éteindre
des gymnases son appel à smart city la
ville intelligente pour les teintes des
gymnases qui sont restés allumés le soir
où
comme on dit ouvrir enfin monter et
descendre les plots vous savez de
parking ou de stationnement voilà c'est
on est devant on est devant le grand
chantier de la ville intelligente de
l'équipement sur un cas comme la tempête
aurore s'est vue voire très vite si un
arbre est tombé à tel endroit tout
simplement être là vous le voyez vous le
voyez l'image vous appelez immédiatement
les services de secours et ça peut être
réglé plus rapidement c'est un outil
extrêmement important pour les communes
et pour les pour les élus mais à votre
avis que la loi qui donc a été on a vu
qui a été voilà qui permet plus de
choses aujourd'hui ce qu'elle doit aller
encore plus loin à votre avis
honnêtement la loi elle est plutôt pas
mal elle est plutôt pas mal parce
qu'elle permet ce que je disais moi
pendant dire mon amendement de faire pas
mal de choses de de permettre aussi à
des organismes publics de de prendre
cette compétence là on peut aller encore
plus loin il ya beaucoup de choses
encore à voir les polices municipales de
se moderniser également il y a aussi les
caméras piéton où ils y allaient
vidéo-verbalisation comme je le dis donc
je pense très honnêtement que dans les
années à venir c'est un sujet qui va
progressivement évoluer au delà des
carcans politique parce que je pense que
comme je le dis maintenant la cette
cyber sécurité ne fait plus débat mais
une dernière question qu'est ce que vous
dites aux autres personnes qui
s'inquiètent aussi de cette vidéo
protection de plus en plus présente dans
notre quotidien qui pourraient y voir
peut-être une atteinte aux libertés
comment les rassurer j'étais là il ya je
crois il ya un an ou deux on avait fait
un débat avec un responsable des droits
de l'homme je crois de lacs des droits
l'homme ce système quand même plus un
peu plus d'un an mais c'était
probablement c'était pavé vous mais
heureux il mentionnait justement cette
ce problème de de droits l'homme on
n'est pas c'est pas la chine on n'est
pas en train de deux d'aller vers ce
modèle là c'est un modèle il faut savoir
que la sécurité est la première de nos
libertés donc ce que je disais à ce
monsieur c'est que plus on arrive à
sécuriser nos villes tranquilliser nos
communes plus on va vers plus de liberté
maintenant il faut encadrer les choses
attention aux dérives et attention à ne
pas filmer n'importe quoi merci philippe
benassaya d'être venu en platine et je
rappelle député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité dix mois de
prison avec sursis et 75000 euros
damende c'est ce qu'a requis le parquet
de versailles contre karim benzema est
depuis mercredi le procès de la faire du
chantage présumé à la sextape au
préjudice de mathieu valbuena se tient
au tribunal correctionnel de versailles
outre karim benzema quatre autres
personnes sont également mises en cause
le procureur a requis des peines allant
de 18 mois à 4 ans de prison ferme de
5000 à 15000 euros damende elle le
verdict pourrait être connu dès demain
vendredi 22 octobre au chapitre
politique le polémiste eric zemmour a
tenu une conférence à versailles au
palais des congrès ce mardi plus de 1200
personnes étaient présentes pour écouter
le potentiel candidat à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 lui qui ne
s'est pas encore déclarée l'occasion de
tester son potentiel électoral dans les
yvelines le reportage de nicolas landry
[Applaudissements]
c'est une salle conquise à eric zemmour
plusieurs générations de personnes
venues de versailles des yvelines et
plus globalement de région parisienne
tous sont venus écouter l'éditorialiste
une conférence organisée au palais des
congrès de la cité royale deux
personnalités politiques biennoises
étaient notamment présentes jean
frédéric poisson et laurence rochât
c'est des gens qui se sentent
suffisamment proche de moi pour venir
passer une soirée avec moi voilà après
vous en déduisez ce que vous voulez
moi je pense qu'effectivement ou non ces
gens là n'ont rien à voir avec les
notables centriste de l air voilà quel
que soit le candidat par un parfum
exotique je suis d'accord avec lui sur
l'urgence des gens utilisation comme je
viens de le dire nous partageons aussi
une même vision de la personne humaine
de sa place dans la société et je
partage avec lui cette inquiétude qui
les partagent et je crois aussi par
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui voit
petit à petit notre pays se déliter
département des yvelines va être une
sorte de petit laboratoire de l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'on voit d'un
côté effectivement que eric zemmour
trouve ici de potentiels électeurs si
toutefois il est il est candidat et puis
de l'autre on voit aussi que bon nombre
d'élus qui a encore un nom était membre
des républicains ont aujourd'hui rallié
le parti dé voir philippe en soutien à
la majorité présidentielle en soutien à
emmanuel macron pour 2022 et si on se
penche sur les scrutins précédents en
2017 les électeurs illinois avait placé
emmanuel macron en tête des suffrages au
premier et second tour les candidats en
marchant ont gagné 11 circonscriptions
sur 12 lors des législatives depuis le
party les républicains a regagné du
terrain dans le département lors des
élections intermédiaires
quid alors de l'avenir du parti à
l'échelle nationale je sais que les
élections sont très bonnes pour pierre
bédier je sais qu'il est indéboulonnable
pour l'instant mais il incarne un
système qui à l'ump un conglomérat
électoral plus exactement qui
aujourd'hui est très en difficulté au
plan national zemmour il essaie de venir
percuter ça donc je sais pas quel impact
peut avoir dans les yvelines mais ce
dont je suis certain c'est que
aujourd'hui il est une menace pour ce
genre de fiefs comme celui de pierre
bédier dans les zi nord parce que je
crois fondamentalement c'est que les
yvelines
plutôt un territoire
d'électeurs du centre pragmatiques
opérationnelles ce qui en tout cas
départ n'est pas un profil zemmour dans
les yvelines le rassemblement national
n'a jamais réellement percé marine le
pen avait obtenu 22% des voix au second
tour lors de la présidentielle de 2017
la question eric zemmour réussira-t-il à
bousculer les lignes politiques dans le
département si les candidats
on parle à présent transport dans ce
journal et plus précisément du projet
eole vous le savez c'est ce prolongement
de la ligne e du rer à 55 km dans
l'ouest francilien plus 55 km et ce
jusqu'à mantes la jolie certaines
polémiques ont éclaté ces dernières
semaines notamment sur le budget total
du dossier et c'est avec michael et demi
d'euros qu'on en parle bonsoir bonsoir à
ma liste à la rédaction de tv 78 c'est
un budget qui déraille michael ce qu'ont
annoncé à certains élus de la région
francilienne le budget du chantier
devrait dépasser le budget initial de
1,5 milliard d'euros plus de 50 %
d'augmentation par rapport aux coûts
annoncés au départ pour prolonger la
ligne jusqu'à mantes la jolie en passant
par poissy et sartrouville cette hausse
a créé des tensions financières entre la
sncf et les élus franciliens qui doivent
avancer la trésorerie face à ce nouveau
dépassement quatre groupes d'opposition
au conseil régional d'île de france ont
demandé ces derniers jours une mission
d'information et d'évaluation du projet
à cet automne si long les travaux
pourraient s'arrêter en janvier valérie
à pécresse la présidente de la région
ile de france a notamment parlé de
scandale d'état à laquelle était invité
dans l'émission face aux territoires sur
tv5 monde c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
que la sncf grandes entreprises en
monopole prenne un chantier et nous
disent il va coûter 3 milliards et demi
et arrivent ensuite en me disant non il
va coûter 5 milliards et demi ou si
l'état est pris par surprise par un
grand opérateur public c'est un scandale
d'état il faut faire un audit un audit
d'ingénierie de sncf réseau parce que ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui à l'ile-de-france
et à la normandie par ricochet peut
arriver aujourd'hui lorsqu'il y aura des
chantiers de tgv de son côté la sncf
justifie cette augmentation par des
retards pris sur le chantier avec la
crise sanitaire et la crise des gilet
jaune le percement d'un tunnel de huit
kilomètres sous la défense dans une zone
dense est également responsable du
retard ces problèmes de financement
pourraient avoir un sérieux impact sur
la livraison du chantier pour l'instant
les panneaux site à proximité des gares
affiche toujours 2024 mais il devrait y
avoir du retard mais eole se fera malgré
à ces polémiques assuré pierre bédier le
président du département dans les
yvelines eole ce sera six trains par
heure en heure de pointe qui partiront
de mantes la jolie pour rejoindre paris
à projets attendu par les habitants des
yvelines nous les avons interrogés ce
matin devant la gare de poissy qui
accueillera ce rer e
je pense que ça pourrait être
mieux pour pour les transports et puis
alléger un peu tout le trafic parce que
simplement le rer a et puis la ligne j
qui vont sur paris c'est un peu
compliqué personnellement je trouve que
c'est assez bien ce que du compte on
prend à se déplacer plus vite c'est une
que j'attends parce que je sais que ça
va être la défense
très rapidement donc avoir sur du long
terme ce que ça donne en fait il attend
patiemment
forcément pour elle à paris-x nanterre
ça va être très très rapide si le projet
va à son terme 700 mille voyageurs
devraient emprunter cette ligne
quotidiennement merci michael pour
toutes ces précisions sur ce projet on
l'a compris très important pour les
yvelinois tout autre chose à présent du
côté de magny les hameaux la commune
continue de réduire les déchets issus
des à temps de repas scolaires est
depuis la rentrée de septembre les
élèves utilisent désormais des
serviettes en tissu à la cantine mélanie
poker
c'est devenu le rituel des écoliers même
quoi depuis le 20 septembre avant de
rentrer dans la cantine ils récupèrent
leurs serviettes en tissu encore
quelques oublis mais la démarche est
déjà comprises j'ai divatte et c'était
bien pour l'écologie de la planète en
gâcherait mois de deux par ippon parce
que le papier c'est fait avec les arbres
et j'aime la nature c'est bien comme ça
on utilise monde serviette et ça fait il
ya moins de pollution tous les lundis on
met la la serviette dans le casier et
tous les vendredis on a récupéré en
place un changement d'habitudes qui
permet d'économiser 100 mille serviettes
en papier par an une volonté de la
mairie une serviette en papier mais
trois mois à se décomposer
ça fait partie d'une démarche plus
globale par rapport à la réduction des
déchets et notamment au niveau de la
restauration scolaire on a d'abord
commencé à réduire notre usage du
plastique de manière générale donc par
rapport à ça on travaille avec des
barquettes compostables par exemple
depuis maintenant deux trois ans la
municipalité a aussi distribué des
gouttes pour limiter les usages des
bouteilles en plastique lors des
pique-niqué au quotidien la ville
introduit aussi des produits issus du
commerce local dans les menus des écoles
un mot de sport avec les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste qui se
tiennent en ce moment à roubaix et après
le bronze aux jo de tokyo les bleus de
la vitesse par équipes se sont adjugé
hier la médaille d'argent derrière les
intouchables néerlandais mais devant les
allemands le trio était le même qu'aux
jeux olympiques ryan hellal florian
gréng beau licencié au vélo club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines et
sébastien vigier tous trois s'entraînent
régulièrement au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bravo hein et
puis avant de refermer ce journal
direction voisins le bretonneux où le
club d'oenologie du centre alfred de
vigny se prépare pour les championnats
de france c'est ce week-end à
menetou-salon dans le cher vinifie cas a
représenté la france au début du mois à
avignon aux mondiaux de dégustation de
vins à l'aveuglé le club qui compte 85
membres en avait aligné 5 pour la
compétition et a terminé cette
compétition des championnats du monde à
la 6e place pour les championnats de
france cinq équipes de vinification
seront en lice pour décrocher le titre
national et michael et demi d'euros a
pris le pouls à quelques jours de la
compétition assez confiant aujourd'hui
je constate d'année en année que voilà
tous les dégustateurs qui sont dans
cette salle on de la régularité c'est
sait ce qu'est le plus dur on peut avoir
une partie qui ne sourit plus plus
facilement avoir de la réussite sur une
partie
avoir de la régularité c'est déjà
beaucoup plus difficile voilà c'est très
exigeant pour être en finale il faut
être dans les six meilleurs sur une des
manches du championnat de france on va
tenter de lettres et généralement on
arrive à peine à placer entre 10 et 16
dégustateurs en finale ça sera
l'objectif cette année bonne chance à
nos vies sinois voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité et
demain vendredi c'est avec le 7-8
week-end que vous avez rendez-vous
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
avec bixente mayence insisté ban pour
une émission vous le savez que de
l'actualité également des idées de
sorties loisirs pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines très belle
soirée avec tv 68
[Musique]